still grounded young pragnanda but he is
on top of the table and today
he faces off against levon neronian here
we go prague with the first move yeah he
starts with this queen's pawn he's been
doing this a lot late a lot lately and
over the last few days we did see some
stats prague scores very well um in the
queen's gambit and against the slav in
various queens pawn openings so what
will level aronian choose white
occupying the center
okay will we see the nimzo indian
defense we do black's bishop coming out
pinning the white knight and uh this
very trendy variation of white's pawn
stepping forward just one square and
irony has been doing this himself a bit
lately from the white side so it's
interesting to see prague
develop like this white's knight coming
out getting ready to castle the white
king black tends to challenge for the
center in the next few moves maybe with
more pawns uh lots of options here for
black and what do you guys think
early days in this nimzo but okay black
ops in the center with pawns now
why is choice by prague
yeah i mean it seems uh very sensible
fighting choice movie fighting choice i
mean just uh sticking to his principles
i mean both players they've got kind of
different preparation prague's like you
know obviously newer to chess than
aronian roan has been around a lot
longer aronian does have the experience
i you know i think i i think this is
going to be the biggest test so far for
prague personally just because that
experience
you know is is very valuable when you're
playing someone like prague but
symmetrical you know this is this is all
just solid stuff at the moment um
aronia mentioned he wanted to play a bit
more uh solid today so he's not taking
any risk with the opening yeah it kind
of almost feels like this could have uh
also come from a kara khan the pop of
botvinnik variation and the pawn
structure very symmetrical and then it
just hinges on piece play and whether
black can freely develop the light
square bishop and it's out so
white maybe has to start putting
pressure on black on these coming moves
yeah and
i'm really intrigued about why the
evaluation bar favors white so much it
looks like black has
kind of achieved everything he wants out
of the opening black is castled as king
has a solid influence in the center
symmetrical pawn structure okay white
bishop trying to copy black's bishops
now and trying to pin uh the opposition
knights white does have the bishop pair
maybe that's a small factor here but
this pin that black's bishop has against
the white knight it's very annoying
white's knight can't move the queen
behind it would fall and that tension is
going to be there for quite a while
so yeah definitely pressure on both
sides but prague is the first one to
have to answer questions how do you kick
away black's bishop
how do you maybe
start pushing forward how do you
activate the white rooks black is just
rock solid right now that's why i'm so
surprised the computer favors white
well pragnanda going into this match is
on top of the table together with minus
calls and analysts here from the world
champion before today's match started
well news you're currently topping
you're playing liam leah today how are
you prepared
no i think it's going to be a tough
match he beat me last time so i'll look
to correct that now good luck to you
thank you
[Music]
hans
does it mean something special to you to
play against anise geary you've had some
banter going on on twitter and such no
nothing special just another game
we're looking forward to a good game
today and uh what have you done to break
a bad streak
oh i actually forgot my smoothie
i forgot my speeding room i guess it's
too late but um
just relaxed and prepared yeah good luck
thank you thank you
[Music]
you are facing the world number one
today again do these matches mean
something special to you definitely uh
pleasure blend him every time hopefully
he will play well today
and getting a win yesterday that helps
the confidence going into today as well
right definitely but i expect this to be
a very tough match good luck
i have to say as always it is hans
niemann the winner of the interviews
forgot his smoothie today was that what
he said yeah he forgot his smoothie he
seemed to be backtracking going back to
his room or something and then he
changed his mind who needs a smoothie
anyway
was it a joke you never can tell you
know it's a good idea to be
unpredictable i think because you it
keeps your opponents guessing and i have
to say
um
sometimes there's like a divergence
between the player's personality and
their style on and off the board because
i mean looking at liam lay you would
think well mild-mannered very friendly
perhaps played a little solid solidly
yeah no crazy crazy games crazy sharp
games you know and if you provoke him he
will suddenly come at you and meanwhile
hans niemann also
he comes across like he could be a
little bit of a thug off on on and off
the board but he's not you know he
actually plays in quite a nice dynamic
way very classical and yesterday we saw
him
use a very unexpected style against
prague under where he tried to hold
hold his position so what can i say yeah
chest style is not personality
definitely no interesting well hans
niemann today he is playing a niche
geary and hans he actually has won the
first games both of the two previous
days so anish he has to be sharp from
the get-go today both of them has lost
all their three matches so far so this
is
an important one for both of them but
we're following game one with pragnanda
and levon aronian a couple of moves
david yeah a couple of moves and
pregnant went for a very committal
decision white did have a backward pawn
on the c file he traded it off for
black's isolated pawn in the middle of
the board so the pawn structure if we
look at it now black's is very
harmonious black has three nice pawns in
front of his king black also has two
potential
strong pawns on the queen side he has a
two versus one advantage on that left
flank but white does have a past pawn
already in the center of the board
whether it's a strength or weakness who
knows yet that white pawn in the middle
is isolated
and it's just about whether aronian can
take control of squares before white's
pieces get active what does have the
bishop pair so long term white is doing
pretty well
but uh who do you guys prefer here
because there's reasons uh to be happy
for both sides i guess
probably um i'd probably pick white
slightly here um just because i like the
two bishops it's quite an open position
so sometimes bishops excel uh when
there's lots of open lines so you've got
that here uh the eye this isolated pawn
as you say can be a strength for a
weakness and um
it's also a past pawn so it could become
a queen later on um and it just seems
like white's got a little bit more
potential but i mean saying that as well
if i was white i wouldn't be overly
happy with the way things are gone
either because black is incredibly solid
has no weaknesses and um i can see this
going wrong as well i can see that pawn
becoming weaker and weaker as the game
goes on so it's not without danger this
position for uh prague at the moment
either and yeah you think i mean which
side would you go for here would you
yeah i mean normally i would say i
actually like playing against this
isolated pawn in the middle i mean i
find the positions to be quite natural
but here it's a different kettle of fish
because you know the position is very
open white has the bishop pair and
you know there's a lot of open lines for
the rooks to start exerting control as
well as diagonals so i would also be a
bit ambivalent like you kind of like
white at the same time
can see that white has to play
accurately in the next few moves just to
kind of keep and maintain that small
advantage yeah i mean even though i like
white
i wouldn't like getting this position as
white
which is quite a weird thing to say so
even though i prefer to be white here i
still wouldn't want to play this
position it's like so do i really like
why not really
contradictions i know i prefer to be
white than black but i don't really like
either side are you allowed not to is
that possible
i think it's a tricky position to play
and um you know i mean the only so i
mean looking at plans
i i mean i was thinking about pushing
the pawn in front the white king two
squares and
then trying to move the night but that
is really risky and this is the kind of
plan where i could see myself doing
and it really backfiring but this kind
of this is the kind of stuff i'd like to
do use my minor pieces uh try to try to
you know throw them into the center of
the board but i mean you know moving
pawns in front you're king you have to
be very careful about doing that yeah
you're right there simon because uh okay
prague has just retreated his bishop to
this square it was attacked previously
and now uh aruni into play but even if
he makes a non-committal move it's all
about this pin how do you break out of
this pin is extremely frustrating white
would love to move his queen somewhere
just kind of connect the white rooks
together uh so that they can now kind of
swing challenge black's rooks which look
great uh challenge for this open e file
or challenge for this
kind of open c file maybe trade off a
set of rooks the white bishops will
become stronger if pieces get traded off
but if you break the pin like this you
still get kicked around with the white
queen you still get hit nice c5 as well
exactly well maybe this is better but
yeah yeah sorry here
you're right hitting the queen hitting
the bishop and uh white can't capture
because the queen would then be attacked
and uh black would win material so it's
actually really awkward i mean maybe
there's a better waiting move
uh by 11 iranian than just waiting with
this rook first he does this kickback
against the white bishop i'm assuming
the white bishop kind of continues uh to
create this pin it's less effective
white's bishop because the black queen
can happily move
after all the knights defend each other
so
i guess white doesn't really want to
trade off his bishop for a knight if he
can't shatter the black pawn structure
this only helps black but still this
question remains right i mean it's it's
really awkward for pregnant so i kind of
understand why both of you
you slightly prefer whites my instincts
say the same but in the current position
lots of questions for prague what do you
do with this bishop first of all do you
retreat it to the edge of the board
where maybe it's not that great do you
retreat it to like a solid but passive
square where it's safe but not doing
much and long term how do you break this
pin i just
don't really see a safe convenient way
of doing so
unless as you mentioned simon at some
point you kind of push this pawn forward
but
in rapid chess against an attacker like
aronian you don't really want to weaken
your king i only wanted to play that
move in combination with my knight
coming forward otherwise i would not be
playing that move if i can move the
knight into the center here
but i only wanted to do this also when i
was pinning the knight so i kind of
wanted everything you know
you know even here i'm like you know
okay
you want it now yeah yeah you kind of
want it all in life don't you if you
can't get it but you very rarely do
especially when i'm playing chess but i
mean
it's but you know this is actually a
common idea in some other variations but
yeah you're moving at g pawn david i i i
don't you know very very risky very
risky and also you still have to
calculate it might not work but you
you'd have to calculate whether black
could in fact sacrifice a knight in
order just to open up the white king
yeah and ideas like this uh as you
mentioned ivanka giving up a piece but
still
kind of fixing this pin forever and uh
very weak king here for white so instead
prague has gone the other way with this
bishop he does indeed maintain his uh
his own pin
so both bishops now kind of
creating these awkward pins on these
diagonals but
as mentioned it's not that awkward for
aronian and here again he could play a
useful move just improving his rook
putting it on an open file just like
this
these two black bricks now fantastic or
another option just move the black queen
out of the way
maybe to a useful square for example
here on the edge of the board flexible
square and break the pin
yeah chances for both sides shaping up
to be a very tense game cool the action
has uh started inside
the miami arena i wonder what's uh going
out outside the arena let's go down to
spider in miami
well except for the fact that we're
absolutely burning up i think it's a lot
going on out here right now i'm being
joined by
a woman here this is bianca mitchell
avila she is a
filmmaker and or actually a docu-series
maker and a former chess player and
bianca you're 17 year old right now you
are traveling the world making a
docu-series how did that come about
well um my dream was to travel around
the world create movies create tv
and chess was my stepping stone for that
i mean i played chess uh since i was six
but not i stopped competitively after a
while and really took on more of like
the community style more of meeting more
people and more of a commun language if
that makes sense like talking to people
learning their stories in chess and uh
seeing more the art aspect of it
and this is important to you as well i
mean you've been a woman in chess and
this is about women and chess
how how how is that inspiration been
important for your life and your career
choice um as a young woman of color i'm
a chicano latina from albuquerque new
mexico um
i was in a club full of men and young
boys and didn't really i only really
learned about bobby fisher and gary
kasparov and my young cousin raquel um
she just started playing chess and so
i realized that i needed something more
when i was younger to see more women
role models in the world so that's
really what made me
go down this route in the chess world
and more of looking for the women out
there and finding their story so that my
family my friends and more young women
women out there can see these role
models and can see that they're
powerful women out there and they can do
whatever they put their mind up to and
that we soon get a female player playing
in the champions chess tour as well
right yes i'm so excited
well we're looking forward to that kaya
getting the for a female player back on
the tour again now but for now we have
eight guys who's really battling it out
yep we really do
and i have to say i'm really looking
forward to that documentary yeah me too
i mean i i love this idea yeah what a
great idea definitely showing visibility
to the women chess players out there
like right now i'm reading this fabulous
book by jennifer shahadi on chess queens
like we all know the history about the
male world champions you know gary
kasparov or bobby fischer but do we know
the female world champions yeah you know
maybe everyone's heard of viramanchik
maybe no no nakaprindish really but
they're
way more than that and it's so great
just to have their stories told
have you know all the female players
just out there and
one of the things that people do forget
is that uh girls growing up their role
models are actually likely to be other
females i know when i was growing up i
was looking at the top british women
players and i was following and
absorbing and inhaling every story that
i saw on the polgar sisters or maya
chiba dinitzi and it's great to have a
documentary that will be highlighting
female achievements yeah we're all for
that looking forward to it
and we have had several female players
on the champions chess for this season
no one in this major though but still
eight fantastic chess players two of
them playing this game frag against live
on ironian what's happening on the board
david yeah talking of
women and it is the year of the woman in
chess uh the queens uh that are about to
get traded off maybe um so the women
yeah i'm not so sure this decision by
prague
um also it comes at a cost getting these
uh queens off the board
what do you guys think if we jump in
just to show what prague has done i
think he was just feeling uncomfortable
due to this pin
um his lady not feeling comfortable eyed
up by the bishop on h5 so he got her out
of the way offering a trade and if black
does capture now and suddenly white does
uh have to maybe take on these shattered
pawns if black captures the knight and
we kind of get this odd scenario it's
two bishops against two knights and it's
quite rare this type of situation first
of all but i'm looking at the white pawn
structure
and i'm thinking oh it's not great
maybe the pawns can step forward in
future especially this past pawn in the
middle of the board but at the same time
black's knights will combine they will
be able to blockade later and
it's anyone's game here um i'm not even
sure which color i would choose to be
honest but uh if levon ironian doesn't
want to do this if he wants to keep the
queens on the board and avoid any
potential end game then i guess he can
for example swing his queen over
and still
this white queen feels a bit awkwardly
placed um still a lot of pressure on
this knight maybe it's your idea simon
that he wants to play bringing the white
knight into the middle but
um somehow it just feels superficial
with this white queen blocking in her
rook next door
and she is on an open file after all at
some point one of the black rooks will
kind of try to target her
maybe it's hanging together maybe prague
has very specific ideas here but
um yeah a bit of a kind of committal
decision at least and i'm not sure he
needed to do this what do you guys think
uh after this white queen move will he
capture will he avoid it
i think it's very understandable uh
because of that pin on the knight as you
pointed out was so so annoying so the
the human response is let's get out of
the pin
um i i don't think i don't think it's so
bad i mean like i think it is certainly
double-edged i've if the queens come off
that
we're gonna have a very interesting
middle game aren't we because uh that
pawn structure is horrible so aronian
decides to keep the queens on the board
and uh now
the rook coming to attack the queen
white's queen does look a little bit
ridiculous as to be said but this night
move um will get rid of a lot of
problems as well you know you're getting
out of the pin
and you're you you know your your bishop
your light squared bishop looks
tremendous i mean i i think this
could be could be all right actually
maybe i'm really surprised sorry sorry i
was going to say this really depends
though on a specific tactic the reason
that black put his queen on this square
is that he wants to jump in with his
bishop too yeah i missed his face
that's that's something i missed i must
admit i yeah which is still very
complicated yeah i'm not sure maybe
white has a way to kind of
get this rook uh kind of save this rook
i don't really see it right now
but uh maybe simon is it time for your
idea for earlier maybe g4 is not stupid
because you know you have the bit the
dark square bishop coming behind it if
you're ever in you know to defend your
king and i i guess black has has to drop
the bishop back
and then when the knight comes in you do
you do have a big big threat knight
takes bishop is winning a whole piece
so where
yeah this this this is uh maybe it's
really complicated yeah yeah this is
certainly an idea can you also um
i do like your idea simon but a little
bit too committal for me right now uh
could you perhaps just deal with the
incoming threat of uh you want to put
your knight in e5
but uh you can't do it just yet so just
move the queen up to defend the knight
and then the next move
okay yeah is it franken hernandez
i was thinking the next move you can go
for it because one idea i really wanted
to highlight is that once the knight
does reach the e5 square white can
actually support it by first playing the
pawn to f5 that's like f4 sorry
and that move kind of also traps the
bishop it's a common idea yeah so for
example if black just kind of does
nothing
i'm not really sure how for example if
he puts pawn pressure on this knight you
back it up and next move you really
feel more confident about going after
this bishop yeah i like that move i mean
again this is white trying to do
everything right i mean you're trying to
get this knight in use your bishops
without weakening your king and um
one of the problems black has is is his
might i mean we talked about a lot of
white's pieces but black's miter pieces
are pretty bad right i mean the black
knights the one and d7 i mean they're
both really bad you know they don't have
any squares they can't really move them
the bishop is becoming a target so um
there is now now i'm definitely saying
okay i will play this position with the
white pieces please give me this
position i would very much enjoy playing
this position against anyone
and i'm thinking that this is this idea
has worked out well maybe erodian's
queen a6 was not the right way to play
yeah it feels like uh with his last move
he was just playing for this trick he's
hoping white's knight jumps in and then
he traps the white rook
but uh yeah this move you mentioned
ivanka that prague ended up playing
looks like a really nice nice solution
just defending the knight
now it's far less attractive for black
to capture this knight because it
doesn't ruin white's pawn structure
suddenly white's bishops are clearly
better than the black knights
and uh yeah advantage prague it looks
like in the current position big threat
of the night jumping in
yeah
and aronia not playing as quickly as
usual as well that's a bit of a surprise
yeah well he did say in the interview he
promised that he was going to take his
time
his hands
follow
the rules and uh
i have to say
but i mean you know the position is
still very complicated and i think can
happen and uh whilst lavon is thinking
well we do have a selfie competition
where we are asking
what send us a selfie that will impress
grandmaster david howell and uh kix says
hi david your commentary at chess champs
is slowly making a grand master
somewhere in nigeria oh
that's a nice one love it i love that
one i would love that come on nigeria
yeah definitely and samuel hoakman says
do you have more trophies than me
i don't
says i love your hometown david the
place is amazing and what a view from
the pier
so basically you got a stalker
that's a sign of having made it right
yeah yeah definitely
yeah brighton beautiful place
and here's your front door
[Laughter]
down that area of britain is
much nicer london i think even so uh
yeah have better weather in brighton
than many other places in yeah yes beach
on the south coast it's it's nice and
sunny and uh lots of nice restaurants
and pubs and pier and it's lovely
history as well
fantastic i mean it's not as nice as
miami i'm going to say
it's england's version
yeah and i also heard so if you want to
invest in wine
you know traditionally french italian
wine the best but because of climate
change british wine is becoming the best
and i can imagine that would be around
that area where they have some
yards
they do have many vineyards down in
sussex yep and around that area so funny
i should know that
but it's a lovely part of the world
definitely it is lovely so yeah
absolutely yeah
and meanwhile i've got to say i just
love prague's attention to detail um in
this last position he's brought his rook
across and i think there's a very clever
reason behind this um if we just jump in
there's only been a couple of moves uh
aronian dropped his bishop back and on
the last turn so prager's just put his
rook on this square challenging for the
c file it looks nice it looks pretty it
looks like the kind of move you just
play without thinking just to uh kind of
play on general principles just
challenge a low profile but if we go
back one move the most natural idea we
were thinking was for the white knight
to jump in but the reason iranian had
retreated his bishop which is actually a
target now the reason he'd put it on
this square is he wanted to trade off
white's best piece and white's best
piece is his bishop and now it's no
longer possible uh to keep it after
black brings his bishop in and uh he
will trade off this bishop
supported by the black rook and prague
this just shows that he's looking at his
opponent's ideas not just his own he
sees that irony wants to trade off his
bishop and uh if these bishops disappear
it's probably just level and uh
therefore he stops his opponent's ideas
and we call this prophylaxis in chess
just
kind of thinking ahead uh killing all
the opponents uh kind of plans and yeah
prague just that real really does show
maturity and high quality
meanwhile ironian tries to insist on a
similar idea he hits this white rook if
the white rook moves for example to
attack the bishop then he can
potentially drop back again trying to
insist on this trade
how is breit prague going to continue
stopping him that's the question so this
is the current position he's attacking
this rook and if the rook moves he wants
to drop back
can we cut across this idea
oh some tempting moves here
i would love to somehow trade off one
set of rooks and then go for this pawn
on the f7 square it looks really tender
in chess in general this is always
black's weakest spot especially if you
have a bishop on the same diagonal as
your opponent's king
i can't quite see a way to sacrifice and
just go for a checkmate though um if we
ever bring our queen in
i think black can just get away with
ignoring it black can probably take a
rook and it's just one check after all
the king will hide in the corner but
already it's a bit scary for aronian his
king coming under fire what do you guys
think
uh is this clever by iranian the
evaluation bar hates his last move if we
go back to the game position
looks clever i mean
white's most dangerous piece is
certainly
his light squared bishop and uh aronia
we talked about erroneous minor pieces
being very bad so why not try to swap
them off so it looks like a very good
idea to to make some trades and also
this could make the isolated pawn
white's pawn in the center weaker
generally when you're playing against
the isolated pawn you want to exchange
pieces generally because that pawn will
be a target more of a target and the
piece is generally like playing around
the isolated pawn so is this is a
decision time how does
prague
stop this idea or do something against
this idea and he's just
moved his rook which seems very sensible
but now
after bishop c4
uh aronian
ronin is starting to find some stability
in his position
i mean is it so clear-cut though
if we were to kind of go a little bit
deeper into the variation yeah the
bishops might come off but still
white has a really active rook
the queen will be well placed the knight
is still springing forward
um
rock solid though so we need i think
it's just the fact that the game has
become a bit more urgent for prague now
and especially if the bishops come off
he needs to be quick long term black is
actually the one with the advantage if
it goes down to just a pure end game all
of the pieces coming off the board if
it's just about pawns black will win
because these two will beat this one
long term and this pawn in the middle it
is past porn but
black's king can easily come across to
stop this pawn later on so uh yeah i
just
yeah i still possibly would choose white
but now it's becoming easier to play for
black if you can guarantee that these
pieces disappear
from the board
and that's why prague is peering in he's
getting closer to his screen he knows
the critical moments
are over the next few moves if he can
create something now he'll have the
advantage if he doesn't
actually things might turn
i mean you can throw your knight in
stuff like this into the position but
i'm kind of i'm kind of starting to
think that some opportunity was missed
by prague
and that aronia would be feeling a lot
more comfortable here
now that he's just going to get rid of
that light square bishop that's a major
achievement for black right getting rid
of
white's probably most dangerous piece
there so yeah i mean you could play this
david but it doesn't even look that
scary to be honest it's a bit scary that
night is very active and obviously you
can see you're pointing towards the pawn
still some ideas so this is some
pressure still maybe this is one of the
better options to to to go for this and
activate the pieces before aronian can
make uh more changes to the position
that will suit him yeah and uh okay we
don't see that we see instead white uh
pinning the black bishop so some tension
now he's brought his rook across just to
create a pin here but i'm expecting
iranian to just deal with that by there
we go defending his piece uh not only
defending his bishop with the pawn but
also now the rook is defended suddenly
by the black queen so the pin has been
broken it's less effective and suddenly
i think i mean we see aronian in his
chair there
he's looking much more confident
just a few moves ago it felt like he was
in a bit of trouble yeah i was really
praising prague
prague's done nothing wrong but aronia
has just found some really clever moves
and also clock time starting to work in
one side's favor and it's not good not
looking good for prague
i have to say a lot of uh the pieces are
close to the white king but the black
king doesn't have that many
pieces that close to it at least does
that mean that prague is more defending
or
is it even
an issue it's not an issue right now i
guess
black's king is not too worried because
the knights are a king's best friend and
black does have two knights in the
vicinity
just within one move or within two moves
they can defend the black king
white's pieces i think they're poised
they're ready to attack okay he trades
off
one of the black knights there i guess
that white bishop wasn't doing anything
on the edge
uh but yeah white's pieces they're not
necessarily defensive they're not
necessarily attacking they're just ready
to play on either side of the board
depending where the action lies well he
did take off that one night that was
okay now there's another night that's
the problem yeah
and normally you don't want to do this
you normally want to leave two nights
defending each other we call them
superfluous knights one of them is
actually useless if they're just kind of
sitting on the same circuit so that's a
bit of a concession that prague made
it looks like a lot is coming off the
board now the less than three minutes
not well okay three minutes for prague
and look at his chair shaking yes
shaking
very concentrated definitely and it's
also that critical game for for
pragnando because do you remember you
know everything was going great until
round four
in the oslo esports cup
so i mean i i don't have forgotten about
it until prague mentioned it himself
yesterday in the in the interview which
does mean that he is thinking about this
critical moment yeah
um one thing i have to say though is
that in this particular position i'm
really liking levron's position it might
not be enough to win
but he has two targets to look at you
know he has these weak isolated pawns on
the d4 square and the b3 square and also
black has the outside pass pawns
remember not paul not all pawns are
equal when it comes to the endgame you
know you have to judge them on their
ability to move how far up they are on
the board and whether they can march in
a connected fashion
yeah they're not past pawns yet but they
do have that potential
and uh okay retreating as queen i'm also
comparing the knights and black's knight
is just beautiful can never really be
kicked away and a white tonight maybe at
some point especially if the queens come
off
white's knight can be kicked by a pawn
so it's not quite as stable
meanwhile
nice solid move there from levon
aurillian just centralizing his queen
yeah it should be a draw with best play
but if the queens disappear i would love
black's position
so prague needs to keep the queens on
needs to keep active he can't allow
black the time to start running with
those two queenside pawns so is prague
only playing for a draw in this game
feels that way um i mean unless he can
somehow whip up a sudden attack against
the black king which looks unlikely
i just don't really see what else white
can try
i would yeah i would choose black here
how about you guys definitely like a
thousand times over but uh the one thing
is that you know of course i also got
our prize in the back of the mind for
selfie competition the grind like a
grandmaster course i'm thinking how
would black try to grind this one out so
first of all i'm thinking the night is
well placed the queen is
has to support the night maybe it's time
to kind of
secure a safe haven for the black king
yeah i think we might well see level
narration do that um that's nice
strategy ivanka magnus with the proof
and just maybe push the g pawn in front
of black's king create a nice safe there
we go
you called it you called it
uh now the black king has a square where
that pawn previously sat it's nice and
safe it won't get checked
and
i think we'll see the king occupy that
square and the reason this is such a
good square for the black king
on the g7 square is that the white
knight
it's actually there's a gap in between
but it's on a diagonal from the black
king so the white knight would always
need at least three moves to deliver any
kind of check to that black king this is
the safest kind of formation just
remember this the white knight to the
black king
if you want to avoid getting forked
checked if you're low on time just go
for this formation we do have a draw
inside the miami arena game one between
magnus carlsen and
liam lee has ended with the draw minus
with the white pieces in that game and
liam will have the white pieces in the
next game starting in 25 minutes in the
other matches it does seem like uh the
bar is indicating this is interesting
the bar is now shifting towards ali reza
for russia's side in game one against
young christophe
duda who lost yesterday in only three
games to liam lehrer through shahi
eventually won his match against
tanishquiri in armageddon and could
already as well win the first game today
anish giri okay it's looking better for
him the bar is over to his side in game
one against hans niemann
and it would be
the first win for a niche gear in the
tournament if he wins this game so let's
see if he can finish it off this time
because that has been the problem for
anish yeah i just looked over at the
game gary against neiman
he needs to win this one if he doesn't
win this one his confidence will be
affected even more because it's a
massive position it's overwhelming he's
uh dominant right now gary all right
just that final touch
this is the big test for him trouble for
hans niemann in game one today
let's see what happens but we are
following prague against uh lavon so
moves on the board yeah meanwhile maybe
a silent draw offer here from uh levon
ironian now if the queen's come off
white can temporarily go upon up that
pawn will disappear though maybe we show
this on the board because it's very
likely to happen and i think prague
should go for this uh just get out of
this game you don't want to be under
pressure too much longer but if you
trade off the queens
and then take this pawn uh then at least
after a check and a capture this one
should be a draw now i'm not sure what
white should play uh maybe you push this
pawn forward one square or maybe you
retreat the white knight it's hard to
imagine uh this game
ending in any other way than a draw both
kings will rush towards the center it's
level pawns
and uh okay he doesn't go for this uh
maybe prague thought that the black king
was slightly more active than the white
king maybe he was scared of the black
king coming into the center first
okay he keeps the queens on the board
but now suddenly look at the black queen
look at the black knight they're both
perfectly placed
can level and take advantage
what do you guys think good decision
ambitious decision i guess
yeah
i don't think you should be playing for
a win really um there's certain times
when you you just have to say okay i'll
take the draw move on to the next game
and i think that ending um was was a
good chance for for yeah just to get out
of this game i i really like what
prague's done over his knight that was a
very clever maneuver uh moving his
knight away from the center and putting
it on the square it's on now so at least
he's put it on the queen side to deal
with those pawns attack those pawns but
black's knight is always going to be a
great piece here and there's this sort
of long-term danger that black will get
a past porn on the queen side somehow
and uh you know that that's just a long
term positional threat here
um
now
i mean you can force a draw i think here
can't you just by checking so this is
going to be interesting will aronia
decide to move on to the next game get
the white pieces it's not it's not a
crazy decision i think he might we've
got to go back to the players because we
might well see iranian force the draw
repeat the position prague leans back
uh yeah i think you guys are right maybe
aronian thinks with black is still a
good result
what would you do would you play on i
would think i would play on i would go
for it definitely you know you've got to
repeat the position twice and then
dangle that draw
in front of your opponent and then at
the last minute you snatch it away and
you say no no no no we're gonna carry on
and with the clocks as well right
exactly much more time on the clock
further exactly i mean how is he gonna
do it i'm not really sure
i haven't worked out that detail yet but
i mean maybe he has ideas of um
okay no gives a check and
he might well go for the draw and there
we have it and i was about to say this
is identical to a game i saw uh that
magnus showed in that grind like a grand
master course queen of knight vs queen
the knight same pawn structure but uh
levon
maybe a missed opportunity if he doesn't
win now he'll look back
at a missed
chance